we were walking towards an Asian family  number seven of them  none of them were higher than my chest  now does that mean I think all Asian  people are short no of course not I know  Asian people are taller than me I'm just  telling you these are the facts of this  particular story  so the grandparents passed us and then  the parents passed us and the children  passed us  and my son slowed down and he looked at  me and he goes  do you think Godzilla was just a  normal-sized lizard  [Applause]  [Applause]  oh  and my daughter said isn't that racist  and I said we will figure that out when  I'm done laughing  because sometimes you just got a letter  buck